my name is nora west allen and i'm the
fastest woman alive
when i was a child my father disappeared
in something impossible
then i grew up and became the impossible
hey everybody it's charlie this is going
to be my flash episode 1 video
they swung for the fences with their
references so there's a crazy number of
easter eggs so we'll do top 10 wtf and
i'll try to keep the video from going
too long just because there's so much we
need to talk about
because they did the flash ring of
course there's a new round of the flash
ring giveaway all you have to do to
enter is be a subscriber and leave a
flash related comment on the video
starting with number 10 we get nora's
intro narration where we would normally
get the berry intro
and if you've ever watched my hero
academia it's a little bit like deku
doing his opening narration this is the
story of how i became the greatest hero
in the world even though nora is a flash
she says that she's not that good she
doesn't have all the skills that barry
has so she's aspiring to be better
number nine nora initially says that her
big quote-unquote mistake was helping
barry blow up the satellite
suddenly i can't go home but the thing
about that is is that later she admits
to lying about that
so even if it was one of her big
mistakes i think that there's something
else going on or they're just using it
as a red herring
there are a lot of other things that
they'll do on accident that will lead to
cicada
beating them in the future when he
shouldn't have in the original timeline
that was why wally had that big
explainer at the end of the episode
where he said there are fixed moments in
time that you can't change and then
there are some moments that are okay to
change
so just remember that they're gonna keep
referencing messing up the timeline for
the first couple of episodes i'm sure
mostly for comedy like please don't give
us spoilers about what's going to happen
they make a bunch of time travel
references stepping on a butterfly is a
reference to the story a sound of
thunder
marty mcfly back to the future
terminator 2
but they go to great lengths to let you
know that nora
is who she says she is she has both
barry and iris's dna
and they spent a couple of conversations
between her and barry between her and
iris about
what it means for her to be there and
why she came back and why it's so
important that she get to meet her
father
so i think that's their way of killing
all the nora
is lying about who she is theories like
she's not the fanboy
younger version of reverse flash
pretending to be nora
number eight barry gets reinstated as a
csi letting you know that he's going to
be doing a lot more
sherlocking that's why captain singh
told him there's a backlog of cases
meaning that he's going to be buried in
work
for most at least the first half of the
season maybe the back half too
nora speeds in and gives you more of her
backstory i'm a csi just like you i went
to the same school like they just wanted
to let you know that she's almost
exactly like her father she idealizes
him they finish each other's sentences
they have the joke about the cookie
dough and you start to get the overeager
nora like she rushes and grabs his
season one suit from cisco's closet in
an
instant fan favorite og flash suit which
they then you know pay off when he's
helping save the guards from gridlock
another fun moment too is nora saying
that she has a 5.6 gpa
when 4.0 is supposed to be perfect
inside the united states
even if she's really naive and she's
making a lot of mistakes she's kind of
like jessie quicken that she's
crazy smart but not necessarily the best
speedster that they can be
yet number seven the big flash museum
name drop so this is just
nora explaining how she learned all
about the flash i studied
everything about your history fun fact
too this is almost exactly like the
reverse flash's backstory he was an
expert
on all things flash in the speed force
he was even
curator of the flash museum further in
the future
so remember nora is from about 30 years
in the future reverse flash is still
from
hundreds of years in the future so even
though there are a lot of reverse flash
easter eggs buried in there they still
want to let you know that nora is
nora nora name drop lightning lad who's
a member of the legion of superheroes
from
way further in the future so i'm
assuming that he time traveled back and
that's when he met nora
but they used all that awkward coffee
talk to sort of set up the ongoing drama
between her
and iris oh yeah you know mom's off
doing her own thing in the future yeah
she's doing fine
the writers didn't say what it was that
was so awkward between them and why nora
isn't so hot on her but they did say
that they would resolve that within the
first couple of episodes so it's not
like it's going to stretch across the
entire season
the shui slang term that she keeps using
is them doing the bart allen thing where
he just says
crash the mode all the time so most of
you probably picked up that the energy
with which she
entered the frame and she was
introducing herself to everyone was very
much like
bart allen especially on young justice
so it's sort of their way of doing the
bart allen character
without actually doing bart allen so
like she name drops all those characters
from the future like ryan choi
she didn't say anything about bart allen
or having a brother so it's just them
leaving themselves room if they want to
do those characters later they could
change the timeline this season
and then by the end of the season it
turns out she does have a twin brother
in the future so they could get the
tornado twins in a roundabout way
but original nora isn't only child
number six though the negative tachyons
it felt like this was their reference to
the negative speed force
even though that's not exactly how the
negative speed force works
the negative speed force was something
that was originally created by the
reverse flash but then later comics sort
of retconned that a little bit so i
think they're just winking at that from
behind the camera without necessarily
pinning themselves down so i've always
wondered if they were gonna use that as
a concept
number five we get the big bomb from the
future newspaper barry asnora she
explains
what happens to him not necessarily how
he dies but that he never comes back
so this is right out of crisis on
infinite earths in the comics
so what happens is barry turns into pure
speed force energy
and doesn't re-materialize until flash
rebirth
but like nora says see this is actually
really accurate he never comes back
in the future that's because when he
came back he came back in the past now
there's been a bunch of retcons
originally what happened is is when he
died in this crisis
moment he turned into the lightning bolt
that gave him his speed force powers
so his life became this loop and it was
wally west who was the first person to
encounter his children the tornado twins
when he became the main version of the
flash
they actually mistook him for their
father are you our dad no i'm wally west
i'm the other flash
the way nora explains it she was born a
couple years quote unquote before
this crisis event so that's the writers
also saying that we're not going to tell
you exactly when she's born so that you
don't know when we're gonna get iris
pregnant and they're gonna have that
baby
so maybe sometime in the next couple of
seasons they've teased it who knows what
they're gonna do with that
number four nora gives him the flash
costume ring it looks exactly like the
effect in the comic book does
it turns out it was made by ryan choi
who is the second version of the atom in
the comics
he became the atom after ray palmer
disappeared after identity crisis
because he was so grief-stricken
so who knows maybe we'll get ryan choi
on one of the tv shows in the next
couple of seasons i would assume that
they would do that character either on
flash or on legends of tomorrow because
ray palmer is on legends of tomorrow
but number three they phase the plane
it's right out of the beginning of the
new 52 flash comic book title they phase
all the people out of the plane and
crash it right in the bay
it's totally cool it looked like it was
right off of the page and
barry gives her the reverse flash
harrison wells speech from season one
exactly they even spliced footage in
from season one so it's sort of their
way of
referencing season one energy they want
to get back to the tone of season one
the balance of humor
and drama and give the energy of barry
being really excited about stuff because
he's so excited because his daughter is
here
wally comes back explaining the rules of
time travel like there are some things
that you can mess with
like i said that's the key to getting
tornado twins you know messing with the
timeline to get even more comic bookie
stuff down the road
but he goes off he's gonna go find
himself i think he's appearing in at
least three episodes this year
but wally isn't on legends anymore so
he's effectively leaving all the tv
shows
number two ralph comes in makes a joke
about the continuity error from season
one
ralph dibny died in the particle
accelerator explosion i still get
a lot of questions about that it's more
of a continuity error
but the way the writers play it off in
this joke is that they blame
flashpoint there could be an alternate
timeline where i died in the particle
accelerator explosion
so that's their way of explaining that
ralph dibny season 1 name drop for all
you asking about that
the bigger reveal though is is that
caitlyn's father faked his death and the
person that signed the death certificate
is actually icicle from the comics the
person that ralph says
signed the death certificate is jor
manchette that's the first version of
icicle from the comics
meaning they're kind of confirming that
that's who caitlin's father is going to
be this season and he'll be the key
to bringing killer frost back out number
one of course was that big wtf with
cicada at the end where he kills all the
metas
you don't see how he does it but they
have some cool special effects with his
speed force dagger
in the way it's glowing just seems like
dark matter lightning so i'm sure
they'll have some fun way of explaining
how it's capable of
killing metas and taking away their
powers let me know in the comments what
was your favorite moment from the
episode and i almost forgot when nora
joked about king shark fighting grodd
they actually are gonna do that later
this season in an episode i don't know
which number it's supposed to be but it
might be the second half of the season
what'll happen is i'll do a trailer
video for episode 2 tomorrow morning
leave all your requests in the comments
below i'm sure everybody has a thousand
questions so i'll do bonus videos for
whatever you guys want i'll name the
giveaway winner when i post that next
video
click here for that new venom carnage
trailer and click here to re-watch the
flash season 5 trailer thank you so much
for watching everybody stay awesome i'll
see you guys tonight
you